please don't freeze your sunscreen
sunscreens are a blend of oil and water
called an Emulsion just like oil and
water it wants to separate everything is
held in place by emulsifiers but this is
just like a temporary stopping point if
you give it a good enough reason it will
separate and freezing is an excellent
reason when an Emulsion freezes the
water freezes first all the water
molecules hold hands and they actually
squeeze the oil droplets together if the
sunscreen separates then you're not
going to get an even layer on your skin
it's like painting your skin with a
separated paint you're going to get
patchy coverage